good morning Hank I'd like to extend a
warm greeting to the nearly 2000
subscribers who have joined us since the
Sarah Palin video hello new viewers my
name is John Hanke is my brother and
this is my puffs so Hank today I'm going
to announce everywhere that I and
sometimes you am / are going to be on
tour for my new book Paper Towns to help
me make that very special announcement I
brought two friends guys the finished
copies of Paper Towns hello there happy
Margo hello there sad Margo Hank I feel
like I'm in a Margo sandwich like
they're gonna crowd me out
I wrote you don't cover me up I refuse
to be silenced so yeah these are the
first two finished copies of Paper Towns
Hank a lot of people have been asking
why Paper Towns has two different covers
like the book inside is the same but
there are two different covers that's an
extremely good question and I'll answer
it in my next video which is gonna be
all me answering questions about Paper
Towns in the tour but in the meantime
I've been wanting to do an extremely
unscientific study I'm hoping you'll
help me out by telling me in comments
which of these two covers you prefer by
the way just FYI the back is the exact
same for both books it's a gigantic
blowing up picture of me and Amsterdam
wearing mismatching argyle socks I knew
I should have worn matching socks that
day alright Hank it's time for me and my
helmet had to announce the tour dates
nerdfighters I sure hope you can come to
one or more event because otherwise it
will be lonely oh but first on Monday
September 8th I'm gonna be in Columbus
Ohio that event is gonna be awesome more
info in the sidebar okay I'm going to
announce the official Paper Towns tour
dates with blue Margo and then shiny
yellow Margo and I will tell you the
Tour de nerd fighting dates that we've
booked so far on October 16th the day
the Paper Towns comes out there's going
to be an amazing launch party in New
York City with Hank and my parents and
the Yeti and secret sister Maureen and
lots of other authors and songs about
Looking for Alaska and ukulele sensation
Julia Nunes that sounds like a rumor you
know blue Margot is probably just saying
that to try to get people excited Hank
right now like a third of nerdfighters
are saying who is Julia Nunes as mr. t
so memorably put it I pity 2/3 on
October 17th Boston with the Boston area
nerdfighters aka the vamps on October
18th my adopted hometown of Indiana
Indiana on October 20th I'm gonna be
back in Columbus because like noted evil
lady baby Queen Isabella used to say I
can't get enough Columbus anybody for
obscure jokes about rumored romantic
Affairs in 15th century Europe no you
sure no okay let's move on October 21st
Atlanta Georgia
October 22nd Miami October 23rd Orlando
Florida where much of Paper Towns is set
on October 24th I'll be in the suburbs
of Chicago on October 25th I'll be in
the city of Chicago the 27th I had down
to Phoenix Arizona the 28th Seattle
Washington the 29th San Francisco
California and then on the 30th
nerdfighter Halloween party in Los
Angeles then I take a couple days off
catch my breath and then Hank in the
Kathryn and occasionally the Yeti and
myself hit the road for the great
American tour to nerdfighting 2008
November 2nd Plano Texas later on
November 2nd Oklahoma City Oklahoma as
if there's another Oklahoma City like
what there's an Oklahoma City vows
November 3rd st. Louis November 4th
Election Day spectacular in Greenwood
Indiana November 5th were gonna be in
Louisville then on November 9th we're
gonna be in Virginia Beach Virginia on
November 10th we're gonna be in
Charlotte's ville on the 11th we're
gonna be in Lancaster Pennsylvania tell
him what we're gonna be on the 12:00
tomorrow
Connecticut Margo I don't want to
criticize here but you have a terrible
voice for vlogging November 13th
Pittsburgh the 14th and Arbor Michigan
and the 16th Ames Iowa I mean if you
live in Iowa and you're not in Ames on
the 16th I don't even think we can be
friends anymore so nerdfighters which
tour stop or stops
are you coming to tank I'm looking
forward to spending three weeks in a car
with you in November I'm sure it won't
hurt our relationship yellow Margot says
best wishes I can't see anything I can't
even there it is